-Today is Friday, and that's
usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some emails,
and of course,
I send out thank you notes,
and I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So I thought
you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that okay with you?
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Gentle music playing ]
-Oh, he's giggly.
He's giggly tonight.
-It's a bobblehead James.
-Giggly James.
-They call him Mr. Laugh-tastic.
-You know how James laughs?
-How?
Let me cut to James.
He goes like --
hoo-hoo-hoo-ha-ha-hey!
Hoo-hoo-hoo-ha-ha-hey!
[ Continues goofy laughter ]
"I play the piano, hey."
[ Laughter ]
-Hoo-hoo-hoo-ha-ha!
[ Gentle piano music ]
-Thank you, Mother's Day,
for giving people the chance
to send their mom an e-card
that will take her 5 hours
to figure out how to open.
[ Applause ]
Why would you?
-Oh, you got me an e-card?
-[ Chuckles ] I like this one.
♪♪
-Thank you, Doctor Strange.
With the ring and the hair,
you're basically
the Paulie Walnuts of the MCU.
[ Applause ]
"Hey, this guy's breaking
my Infinity Stones over here."
-"Oh, I open the portal, hey."
-Ohh.
-"Hey, MCU. Heyy."
-"Hey, MC-you!"
-CBD!
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Kentucky Derby hats
for making it look
like you wandered
into the back of a pizzeria
at the exact wrong moment.
It's like, ba-ba-dee -- oh!
[ Applause ]
-Thank you,
Thomas' new line of
muffin tops, for being honest
about what's going to happen
to my stomach after I eat you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, Star Wars puns that
make me remember the date,
like May the Fourth
and Revenge of the Sixth.
You're fun, but now I got
nothing between now and --
[ Laughing ]
Between now
and Octobi-wan Kenober.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, dude.
Come on, man.
It's Octobi-wan. Woo!
-Octobi-wan Kenober.
-Yeah, like Roctober. Yeah.
-Thank you, wedding gift
registries for showing me
that our friendship is
definitely not worth a Vitamix,
but is maybe worth
some bedsheets and a spatula.
Maybe?
[ Applause ]
Thank you, mint juleps,
for sounding cute, but really
meaning Grandma has been
pounding bourbon since noon.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank you notes.